if you are new to google cloud it can
sometimes feel like there's a lot of
information to absorb when trying to
decide what to use because of the huge
list of products available so this is
why we created a new and simplified page
to help you get started quickly on
google cloud in a handy five-part menu
just head to cloud.google.com then
getting started let me give you a quick
tour
for starters we have three main
essential buckets the first is learning
how to sign up for a free trial
the second is exploring how to try out
different products via our quick start
tutorials
and the third is once you are ready to
get started with google cloud you can
review common developer use cases
or an enterprise checklist
when you scroll down a bit more for
those who are looking for a macro level
view of our entire suite of offerings
our amazing team has put together a
helpful color-coded cheat sheet listing
all our products and their functions in
four words or less and their respective
features that you can hover over
we also have documented guides that
range from giving you a bird's-eye
overview of google cloud or compare
cloud services with azure and aws as
well as review architecture references
diagrams design patterns and best
practices for migrating your workloads
to google cloud
oh and here is my favorite place
stay in the know with developer news and
community resources by checking out the
developer center to join our dev
community
and
join the google cloud innovators program
where you can receive invitations to
hear from google cloud executives and
developer advocates like myself
see roadmap presentations and a chance
for an invitation to join our new series
of innovator community events
it's kind of like that vip club at
the dev center features highlights like
our new architecture diagramming tool
where you can build architecture
diagrams see reference architectures and
even do one-click deployments directly
to google cloud
and now that we got a high level
overview let me walk you through a
couple of different examples
let's take a look at some of the quick
start tutorials
you can browse a catalog or search for a
specific item to learn more whether it's
on getting started topics like security
enabling apis using the command line
interface sdk called gcloud creating
workflows identity and logins performing
investigations etc
there are also more advanced specific
topics like databases storage options
container vms private ips hosting of web
apps or services machine learning and
more
when you head to common developer use
cases we have a mix of useful videos and
articles organized under a range of
topics in a friendly interface
when you are ready to learn how to build
on google cloud we also have launched an
improved documentation homepage so that
you can more easily find guides code
samples tutorials and api references in
addition to our architecture assets
and there you have it a quick
walkthrough of our new getting started
resources we hope that you check them
out for now this is stephanie wong